un autre groupe de jeunes de montréal la
plupart d'âge mineur ont été arrêtés ces
derniers jours par la grc encore une
fois on les soupçonnait de vouloir
quitter le pays pour aller combattre aux
côtés de l'état islamique ils ont été
interrogés puis ils ont été relâchés
sans cligner d'accusation faute de
preuves karine alors on se souvient
qu'il avait eu un appel pour dénoncer
les comportements suspects et là dans ce
cas ci ce sont des proches de ces jeunes
là qui ont alerté les autorités en fait
ce sont des parents qui ont décidé
d'aller voir la grc d'alerter la grc le
plus rapidement possible parce qu'ils
ont appris que des gens sur internet
solliciter leurs fils pour qu'il se
rende en série pour avoir une vie une
vie meilleure alors rapidement une
enquête qui était déclenchée par la grc
un groupe de jeunes qui est arrêté ils
ont été longuement interrogé certains
pendant plus de 12 heures par la suite
ils ont été relâchés aucune accusation
n'a été portée contre eux donc la quête
se poursuivent du côté de la grc la grc
qui n'a pas voulu commenter il
yad'autres fabien d'autres jeunes qui
étaient partis qu'on soupçonne qu'ils
sont partis faire le djihad en séries et
il y aurait des liens entre tous ces
jeunes là parce que un des jeunes qui a
été arrêté vendredi a effectivement des
liens sur les réseaux sociaux avec les
jeunes qui sont partis justement à la mi
janvier si on regarde dans son profil on
peut voir effectivement qu'il était
inscrit à deux ateliers donnés par le
centre communautaire islamique de l'ess
d'adil charkaoui tout comme ces jeunes
qui étaient partis à la mi-janvier donc
effectivement il semble y avoir des
liens entre ces jeunes et ceux qui sont
partis à la nage et dans ce cas ci ce
qui est peut-être plus inquiétant c'est
qu'on parle de jeunes certains d'âge
mineur voilà c'est effectivement des
jeunes de 15 à 17 ans un arrêt 18 ans
donc ce que ça veut dire c'est que c'est
des jeunes qui fréquentaient l'école
secondaire selene ils n'étaient même pas
au cje a pu imaginer donc effectivement
c'est très inquiétant tout ça mais je
vous rappelle il n'y a pas eu
d'accusations ces jeunes ont été
relâchés très bien merci beaucoup on va
suivre cette affaire bien sûr merci
quand même je vous en prie